this video I'm playin hah gay again and
no surprise he places usual opening oh
yeah okay Oh a surprise that he keeps on
doing that it literally that great I
mean okay yeah miss Blake is okay and
let's let's see what to do c5 is an idea
I'm wondering about Bishop f5 if you
maybe place g4 then
[Music]
[Music]
maybe maybe you'll play that 27 is no
good I have a have a funny idea here I
will try that for Queen f5 activating
the Queen like that it looks a tad
strange but mainly it's an idea coming
at five g5 this kind of thing yeah I
will please try to prevent your form so
what is he up to long castles I will
take f2 and maybe I should have played
cringe five-year just just clean up 25
what is the ease of home to cover that
and I don't I don't know which III was
good i will see
become too okay yeah anyway
[Music]
I have really ok I mean it makes my
bishop more passes that definitely is
the cave so long that I expected
something like this it was six and okay
so you just allows that trait without
any effort on my part I didn't know she
may be look change therefore look lift
to possibly turn to g6 Oh fYI uses this
this this idea with the pin that
something that I did not see as only
thing f 3 which is really bad okay and
it is plain simple strategic move I had
g5 as well maybe that was a good idea of
it I mean in this position I'm just
internally better because of his bad
bishop so this is not a bad choice
just I will just play against this not
not do anything fancy against of King
Koopa 2 g-3 z and then the right moment
fight is going to be played ship here
probably and then g5 quickly plate I can
store the fenders somewhat don't look
particularly attractive but he keeps
everything everything covered at the
moment
Andrew cute chicks strongly bad still
want to play this F form and like the
player for mid care to activate the
rupee on the third-ranked the question
is what is doing with this beep or now
does he play that be six or just take so
on I mean quite sure that's very
ambitious but maybe it's good
can it didn't work out so well with him
g5 was badly time we'll probably it was
all a matter of timing the position was
really bad for white but I probably
missed time there miss time to play them
quite badly Priya shame always say if he
gets away with this bad opening anyway
so let's see what to do here III who it
doesn't do all that much probably yeah
but I need to get some activity going
here I didn't think about that move but
ok let's take take him I don't think he
can we took a look ok didn't expect that
so we tries to go here at the end ever
when g2 is so that is not a big issue
King x5 doesn't help really
time learning once told me maybe I
shouldn't have done that I mean it gives
it gives him this check at the end and
just shuffled back and forth I cannot
win here anyway okay
probably really just the draw g3 I
cannot play
[Music]
check
hmm I can chick okay okay add it to draw
cool check check check check girl off
jet life forfeit on Tony Mary often ask
nothing not much more than I can do
really and he has 45 seconds to take it
yeah anyway that was I'm pretty and I'm
really unhappy there I mean this is just
a bad opening it's just what it is I
don't I don't like it at all so yeah I
mean why this fighting for equality if
you ask me the engine actually likes it
says things that's equal may I don't
like it sorry anyway so going here and
fix c5 I cannot believe in that
computer pings is okay once the castle
short there must be a reason why those
things are rated 3,000 something and I'm
just 2400 anyways the way the way it is
way it went I know sorry come on why is
right better according to stock richness
this is just nonsense what can never be
better I mean okay 0.2 is not much but I
mean really they have a dead we should
there on be too I mean I can just draw
by doing absolutely nothing and
therefore its kind of many questions I
don't know how is this position better
for white in some in some regard I mean
black handle space advantage and to
potentially better bishop how can white
be better I mean I kind of understand
that it might be equal anyway so yeah so
here I mean I just have to play I just
sorry have to time this better because
white only has this is for me five maybe
in yeah the computer wants to also do
some pre-emptive looks like a five maybe
this is right I played it very directly
and maybe that wasn't wasn't that great
would be eight by the engine may be 46
or something like that yeah some system
some sophisticated move like that maybe
can do the trick but I'm in here text
eggs this seems wrong cream cheese six
immediately and then Bishop to g5 of
course yeah of course this is a much
more logical way of doing it
I'm some are thinking I need to share to
play a forward of course I just have to
put it here and now now that's a lot
stronger yeah this is this one great the
engine loves that and I didn't see it
could I can just take you to how I
didn't consider that move actually
didn't see that the rook is hanging at
the end but still so what table to this
I've got to check again I have got the
check okay didn't see that yeah i played
this move and again i can take but this
so so it's always kind of okay then in
this game but yeah yeah i think it
should be a drawer if it just goes
absolutely nothing i'm an idiot tf4 i
just saw it i just saw it yes sir and
you just win so easily what is the nice
ones the night motif just King at four
alright so this is why you shouldn't
take care just stay here yeah and the
book Elia is probably a draw yeah that
wasn't necessary so that engage me that
is still a role you cannot do much there
can never win with the deposit just a
draw yeah ok guys thanks for watching
you